una victoria para los conductores de
uber en reino unido- que siembra un
precedente mundial tras perder una
apelación ante la corte suprema del país
uber concederá a los 70.000 conductores
británicos de ese servicio el estatus de
trabajadores a partir de ahora el
gigante tecnológico les pagará un
salario mínimo así como sus vacaciones y
también deberá inscribir los en un plan
de pensiones
huber es solo una parte de una industria
de alquiler privado más amplia por lo
que esperamos que todos los demás
operadores se unan a nosotros para
mejorar la calidad del trabajo de estos
importantes trabajadores que son una
parte esencial de nuestra vida cotidiana
el salario mínimo en reino unido es de
872 libras por hora unos 12 dólares para
los mayores de 25 años uber informó que
habrá algunas limitaciones a ese salario
que sólo se aplicará cuando los
conductores estén realizando un servicio
y no desde el momento en que inicien
sesión en la aplicación tampoco aplicará
para los conductores del servicio de
repartición de comidas uber it's en
reinounido de las personas con estatus
de trabajador tienen menos derechos
laborales que los reconocidos como
empleados quienes además tienen licencia
por enfermedades y por maternidad o
paternidad a pesar de ello el caso
siembra un precedente mundial en la
lucha por el reconocimiento de los
derechos de los conductores de estas
plataformas en la unión europea debaten
nuevas reglas para proteger a los
trabajadores de este tipo de servicios
sin hasta el momento lograr avances
sustanciales